come on that's Fred Durst
yeah bro I miss that guy man who due to
a friend of mine a couple of months ago
are we rolling keep rolling let me just
get that for you keep rollin rollin
rollin rollin keep get what old man
nobody asked for that do you not you
know feel today oh I love Fred Durst yet
I'm still celebrating my freakin win bro
dude you're not from Toronto you're a
hype [ __ ] huh no dude this is great you
would like in Toronto Raptors on which
no one really follows a mess you're in
Toronto
I need a Cleveland Brown shirt on which
really no one falls through I love the
Cleveland Browns do ya we yeah we both
do
Bernie Kosar whatever I bought a pint of
his blood off the internet when he was
trying to read it his house back yeah I
bought a Eric Metcalf sock one time
really cuz he went to jail for I think
allegedly that's very crude no this is
this is that's rape Carruth and this
dude Eric Metcalf I think what's a jail
for touching a lot of people that he
shouldn't touch you know you think you
would in yer no they look exactly they
do not look exactly we get a picture of
uh is Chinna near June dolloway
it's Kara barracks back in here oh
that's a Japanese sound man cat cat she
was like this my bad Eric Metcalf was
one of the best players everyone on the
video game Tecmo Bowl and I thought he
went to jail for something no dude
you're thinking of OJ Simpson
bro you feel me remember Eric Metcalf
yeah look up the news on him real quick
though I'm thinking of somebody else why
you hate on Eric Metcalf again you're
thinking of who played for the New York
Giants
no New York joint would you return punts
for New York Giants what do you mean who
returned there's a lot of guy well this
was a specific guy that did crime after
I just go and look and see if it says
any crime just grow up but don't
mouths I'm not that mountaineer metcalfe
he seems like a great guy look for the
crime Emerson alive he's a coach at
University of watch I was doing great
he's killing it I'm pulling his name
right into the sink right now I'm
washing it off
Eric Metcalf is a legend okay Eric
McAfee is a legend but not as messy a
legend Oh sounding like you uh it's
crazy when I'm [ __ ] bandwagon [ __ ]
original mediately I can't speak well
you know we're a couple hot boys right
now like damn wagon babies boy yeah we
the north yeah no dude shush I'm one of
us he's in Portland tell me what happens
dude oh you're thinking game of thrones
east yeah Game of Thrones he's done yeah
bro dude Cleveland Browns huh yeah Baker
Mayfield brah you're a fan but you
thought Baker Mayfield was a place to
get a donut bro he was married to mrs.
feel it yeah it's not even that good of
a joke I got a present for you dude
do you really piece of [ __ ] with the
Toronto Raptors Jersey freaked out uh II
already have wondered then you watch the
last week I want a quiet Leonard bro
well first of all don't even try to say
his name again okay you don't know who
he is
row it's just like the place kawaii oh
yeah all right what do you got dude I
got this for you I know you got this I
got I know you got a son and a new
little one on the way
so brother you got a little pair right
here thank you Doug
hello Willie well that's a little one
right there he's got a little one that's
the pop one here
hey that's tiger and that's the kid oh
thanks brother whatever the kid's name
is gonna be which I'm assuming
everyone's assuming will be an animal
yeah
we're leaning towards liner panther
right now okay we'll see okay we'll see
bro get an endangered species at least
draw awareness dude Panthers are very
endangered pit bulls are endangered whoo
that's good point if pit bull taking
though pit bulls take yours true Jesus
turtle
mr. worldwide mr. worldwide Derrick's
back what up bruh bruh how are you man
welcome back where were you oh man it
was Pauly Shore in [ __ ] Florida man
it was awesome Wow for a trial
no he's still doing comedy in - no I'm
actually him he might be I don't know
what that's probably paulie's a legend
no he's the greatest but he still might
be doing a scene oh man - what do you
really know - I hoped it I would love
that bro what if he came back and didn't
see no man - I wasn't trying to make a
joke though yeah I wish they did movies
that were mashups like Encino man meets
mrs. Doubtfire and they fall in love or
Encino man turns into mrs. Doubtfire
no yeah like he's babysitting the kids
and then she kicks him out and he comes
back as a woman uh-huh I like that
actually it's a pretty good idea
actually how you got it is the question
did you have fun Dee oh my god so much
fun dude yeah you got you legs like a
monta yo take off huh
apparently just take off was with my
family for a week bar black people's
barbecues don't last five weeks as you
said oh you heard that sorry black
people barbecue is not automatically a
family reunion it has a very is very
similar to Indian culture on notice
you'll see like a Indian barbecues of
the park - three months bro you see
though like some of those barbecues but
sometimes black family reunion it just
keeps going you know yeah we we didn't
have all matching shirts on did you
really yeah of course hell yeah crazy
shirts yeah we're posting team like
names on the back damn right you did and
so what do you guys do is it was it
really like a big family event yeah we
just Universal Studios all the theme
rides and parks and [ __ ] was fun I just
go as a big group you all dress the same
yeah one of Brandon's favorite things to
do
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh yeah my dad made us watch the
water show every [ __ ] night oh wow
dude you learn Asian bro that sounds
like a very Asian thing watching a water
show every night
radiation hey I didn't see these
pictures though you didn't post any
pictures I didn't know my family was
posting every second so I was like I was
gonna try to enjoy this gram hunter
Thanks well welcome back man we had
angry chin in here and cats back to from
her car accident dude how about this cat
gets in a car accident right chin his
car gets stolen yesterday away and then
talk about CT you know how it got stolen
you and filed a police report and the
cop goes where'd you leave it Lasius
well I thought I parked it they said did
you park on the right floor before he
filed this report once you go back and
look through the other floors
turns out he he parked on the 4th and
said the fish yeah and he wouldn't go
look first at that I deal it's the
crater bro I'm telling you oh my god
what chin you could have parked you a
police report even told the fleet and
the fleet you know what the police know
him being such a policy go check the
fourth floor put on Aggie and beat
people's ass dude yeah dude become a
superhero that fights crime road repairs
that thing when early Asians came to
America they were look at it look at
some of those early movies Jackie Chan
who else gently gently
LeBron rumble in the Bronx to Maui hot
shower one two are we guys who were
kicking ass when things weren't going
well
big trouble a little China we get police
report chin no please report lucky
here's the thing calls me Aiko someone
stole your car he was yelling but you
drive a Prius yes that's what's weird I
don't know man yeah
don't steal a Prius what'd you do
investigated elevator one for lower
let's check out there bro what's your
superpower losing your car in a parking
lot
hey what's your superpower snitchy are
these new Asians I'm telling you man
weak man they're soft that's the thing
look if you got da ya know we know but
there's no there's not room for soft
people anywhere so you got to tighten up
ten your super power can't be
complaining and padding your pockets as
you walk down a stairwell because you
can't find your car your keys yeah you
see we probably can't be losing your car
and writing Yelp reviews and it's not
enough people come on
that's are so disappointed dude there's
some kung fu man learn something to
learn to bake be a tall Baker throw
Chinese stars
yeah well that's pretty you can find
something more creative than that dude
name someone doing it dude you could be
the yeah Ming of Chinese checkers burger
like seven you're like six and a half
feet tall just stand in the middle of
the board and post up join us funky yeah
you wanna spelling me bro
chess club yeah probably not a cop
though you know yeah what's that crowd
I'm like get him should we kick this off
what was petered out you guys ready to
go no yeah it cats back from that
accident yeah you get something he tried
you suffer any trauma from that no I
feel okay but I was not the one who hit
somebody's what they don't see it a pole
sir oh did I say hit a pole yeah last
episode and everybody do me like typical
Wow well he also he has fantasies of
every girls being strippers as well so
it was like dude that's what he might
admit I don't know but you talk about
how they do it touch me
I said that yesterday bro he comes up to
me after a stage he goes he goes don't
touch me bro but keep talking because
that's what Brendan toys hey cat so with
your accent someone just rear-ended
rear-ended you yeah a moving truck
rear-ended me a moving truck see this is
why you people struggle with rust
driving I'm sure you into the truck I am
100%
he just hit you yes it was a bunch of 19
year olds yeah they were working like
summer jobs for a moving company and
were they hot excited when you got when
you got out of them were attractive or
any of them like kind of like nervous or
whatever what I mean one guy was nervous
but that's because he screwed because he
was the one driving they definitely all
got fired
dude I hit a fine girl one time over off
26 man than bad dude no joke bro guys
talk to her for a couple of seconds and
I do it sometime I wish I could hit her
again just to follow up trying to find
her and just hit her just go kick her
car dude
no not gonna kick her yes alarm up
that's nothing she's hot though bro
least had this checked his busted lady
bus I would always wash her car with
just water no soap no and she'll be like
I'm fine
what'd she find them no no no no she was
okay looking but it also it was late you
know was late at know the Sun was
setting you know yeah so everybody looks
good kind of right after the Sun sets a
little bit especially if they're
outdoors to Washington all right D let's
kick this thing off dog we the north
baby my rafters Lowery in the boys that
are in the boy is feeling Browns solving
the boys is dude I look look I love
Baker Mayfield I see obj though just
tanking that [ __ ] man it's the ego
battleship over that is worried about
the guys EE no way back with his boys
roommate from LSU Landry you should be
celebrating these boys I'm excited for
well also they sold Eli Manning throwing
to him no no that's at New York that's
new yeah you said he got Baker Mayfield
slaying that rock they get that dope
tight in there you're a good defense
getting the brown damn we the Browns
around it's gonna Brownsville baby on a
brown go up on that train right now like
this lets you toss out [ __ ] from Pride
Week is over over you gotta get back on
the straight and narrow dude yeah you
roll your dick up bro you gotta tighten
up your dick back in your pants bro
alright let's get into this episode
Derek's back cat is recovered from yet
another car accident G and chin still
doesn't know where his cars at yeah
we'll figure it out oh yeah okay now it
totally describes chin a hundred percent
he's the kind of guy who can't find his
car and eat only looks on one floor and
then goes to the police department and
what a weird cop was like dude get out
of here yeah could be in a [ __ ] yeah
unbelievable man support the podcast
here's an ad look man if you're like me
bro and you're not always paying
attention to your banker who is more to
anything and it gets overdrawn but it's
too late you know I spend thirty seven
dollars on a cup of coffee because the
bank fees yeah it's like overdrawn like
when you over draw a bow and arrow dude
and you're aiming for one thing and you
know you're aiming for the target he's
gonna cost you oh you hit the neighbors
uh parakeet you know and that parakeets
gonna cost you it's guess what
now there's the Dave app putting end to
overdraft fees for good
yup no more of those 3735 those
different fees you're like oh man it
cost me just to even take money out
because I overdrawn Dave is the number
one budgeting app in America because it
saves you from overdraft fee's tells you
about upcoming bills and can advance you
$75 from your next paycheck with no
credit check and no interest that's hard
75 yeah dave app and for just one dollar
per month that's 12 dollars a year which
is way less than an overdraft fee and
you'll never have to pay one ever again
yeah Dave is your boy Dave is your boy
dave is right there trying to help you
out trying to save you that soft 75
he'll help you budget for upcoming
expenses text you if you're spending too
much if you up all night and you
partying with your buckos and next thing
you know you're trying to get more and
more cash god I wish I had a friend like
Dave listen Mark Cuban is an investor in
David because he got crushed by
overdraft fees in his 20s so you know
what let's check out Dave's
three million people are used Dave to
save up to $1,000 a year in overdraft
fees that's why it's the number one
budging app in the App Store yep and hit
them Dave we'll get you that soft 75 and
when you need it go to Dave dot-com / K
80s and never pay another overdraft fee
again so you just need to download the
app and then go to Dave dot-com / K 80s
spelled just like it sounds da ve Dave
comm / K 80s yep download the dave app
and go to Dave comm / K 80s it's
immediate savings thanks Dave
that soft 75 time to buy few more pants
yo man Robin Hood is an investing app
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETS
options and cryptos all commissioned for
you serious or you liar tuck no I'm not
lying or tuck in anything while other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade Robin Hood doesn't charge any
Commission fees plus I heard is this
true that there's no account minimum
deposit needed to get started so you can
start investing at any level
you heard right bro it's simple easy to
you Rob Robin Hood makes investing easy
for newcomers and even experts yeah why
go to these fancy places that you got to
spend all this extra money to invest
you're trying to make money
spend money it's easy to understand
charts and market data right there on
Robin Hood
you can place a trade in just four taps
on your smart phone with Robin Hood you
can learn how to invest in markets as
you build your portfolio discover new
stocks track your favorite companies and
get custom notification for price
movements so you never miss the right
moment to invest yep Robin Hood is
giving listeners of King and the sting
of free stock like Apple Ford or sprint
to help you build your portfolio get you
started look at the charts have a game
plan
sign up at King sting dot Robin Hood
dot-com that's right sign up at King
sting dot Robin Hood com yep start
investing someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit you wanna start a
little rip my drift yeah yeah let's rip
it up first up is Ben Lefevre from Great
Falls Montana
Oh gang bro damn what's he say he's
originally from Vernon Parish Louisiana
oh yeah Louisiana boy and he's just a
swamp kid living in Big Sky Country
beautiful out there man it looks nice
ripped jeans I bet that's from doing all
that that yard work he'd definitely buy
him like that oh that's nice cut away
these frauds out here in LA do well
sometime a lot of kids they used to stay
if they had a dog or a strong strong cat
that was sharpen their nails and let him
get on their pants a little bit to give
him that uh sort of what they call it a
creek what does it wast or something
gene look the denim wash the stone
washed and washed stone wash where they
put a bunch of stones in the pants and
beat their pants against the ground like
tie off the legs and beat him against
the ground and get that same vibe [ __ ]
looks fired though this guy's natural
this guy's relaxing on the chair I like
that also you can see he's holding his
beer can but he's resting his elbow on
his thigh which is kind of a I prefer to
actually hold my arm fully in the air I
like the rest of it like this really
kind of like the Big Sky kid over here
yeah chill you know I'm saying also is
that a joint in his hand or is that a
cigarette that's America that's a damn
joint is that a is that a doobie D
that's one of them Big John son
looks like a doobie doobie oh it's kind
of like this kids style set of brows on
him as well oh yes a life guard for the
worst swamp in the world isn't let's
just say this bro ain't having any
trouble opening up his browser okay this
dude's got some Google browser oh he's
got some [ __ ] safaris right up above
his head some Google Chrome boy we got
to we got to fire foxes running circles
around his eyes looking like they trying
to fire [ __ ] this boy's beautiful Dupuy
one of the top 60 or 70 looking young
men in this area I would bet cosign yup
he has on a tank top and in a dank
bottom brother students down the [ __ ]
probably looking to [ __ ] I don't know
who knows if he has man it looks like he
probably you know I was considering
going to school but not really sure he
just got done with a gay pride going
raid and he's just chilling man
exhausted you're right actually it could
be that he just got done he's just like
I'm gonna smoke a joint have a cold one
and chill out man watch the kids at the
swamp man there's nothing more better
than just laying somewhere and just
doing nothing bro praise God man that's
that's that's America yeah I salute this
young fella man and get it together burn
and perish passing is bumper-to-bumper
here we got Robert and Julie from Culver
City Oh
what were tryin to rip they both look
very short could be the camera showed he
want a thug boy Oh showed he found a
whoa look at the titty committee meeting
up right on Julie's chest saying they're
having a little afternoon convention
right there yeah where she is this side
of business meaning she showed up with
him tits out this is from this past New
Year's when he proposed that night and
she was ready with them pants looking
like a little a little Jersey Shore
mermaid Oh bro she looks like I'm dizzy
from them tits bro it looks like a blur
may dude I can't even get a good look at
him again I can't see him I'm seeing
something do you know what's so funny I
haven't even looked at him
no but they look like a good young
couple it looks like maybe they're about
to get a house together something how
old are they really don't know they are
but they're seeing you at the Mirage in
Vegas in August oh they want you to be
their wedding officiant oh they're
looking to get divorced oh wow so
they're actually looking to get Oh a
wedding officiant what do I do
nothing usually give this order not it's
not that gathers hands there with the so
know you can item you can basically
whatever you want
Oh y'all nighttime dude I'm not doing
all night though I'm not doing all night
man I'm not doing a threesome no no
you're not doing anything like that I'm
staying in my room you might be a kook
you know I'm saying no I'm not doing
anything like that you're an idiot dude
it's not my thing it's his your old one
his girls tits for the past 30 minutes
he hasn't mentioned that you mentioned
it no you brought it up does it say
everybody a lovely mermaid only thing we
know about him is Julie is worried that
her old-school Italian father will not
like this outfit I mean she ain't lying
well big catch a swift palm to the face
dressing like that out the house I've
had some rare uh pescado and uh this is
definitely some she's dressed like a
real mahi-mahi right here if you look at
her you know it's like a nice little
tortellini something no that's not a
fish you delinquent yeah but they're
Italian brah okay you know barely meet
you halfway on this one thanks bro
no but you seem like a nice guy Brendan
and this guy seems like a good guy yeah
he seems cool so it'll work out
I think it'll work out look at a man
they they seem like they love each other
they both looking in the same direction
and smiling before short well I don't
know if they're short you know I can
tell you and I'll tell you there how do
you know but I can just tell how do you
know tall people are mmm she has big
heels on they just look shorter I don't
think so look at that plant do you see
that and that is a big plant D what do
you think short she looks they look I
don't look like about five seven or
that's I'd say five six five seven they
could still grow me you guys have no
hope no you have some little meatballs
running around right now
no I'm I had some little euros yeah
that's what I like them beef gyoza I was
boy yeah you that rigatoni out the
Mirage dude I'll put one of those in the
corner of my mouth like a damn dip and
shoot hoops
those beef gyoza was he ever had him I
haven't
[ __ ] let's go on man but good luck and
look so if the weddings the same weekend
I'm there I'll be inefficient but I'm
sure I got to do the show yeah you know
if I could run over there and efficient
you know for a little you could do it
after yeah be a lifeguard or something
at the pool if they want to do a swim
after yeah you jump in and save them no
I'm not gonna save men they got each
other they there's gonna save each other
do something bro no lazy about if you're
gonna do it go full-bore yeah you're
right that's dress up bro yeah I'll do
something put a tuxedo on well tell them
thank you for the invite and uh we'll
send him um we'll send him a wedding
gift how about that it's at least we can
do certain one of our new merges yeah
awesome I like that I wore one of them
the other day
mmm the Catholic yeah the cow dude we
should maybe get a shirt says gang
getting on the front and buzz buzz on
the back or vice versa brilliant idea
don't touch me where what keep touching
me don't touch me but also keep touch me
but I'll text me but keep touching me
yeah hey your mirror I said don't touch
me definitely keep that prison nickname
yeah up next we got a Thomas aka
strictly sick strictly sick oh yeah oh
yeah he looks when you'd be a little
sick and this is somebody that it's
never quit listening to Nirvana or some
41 yeah yeah it's 21 he looks like he
listens to Fall Out Boy really yeah it's
some 41 isn't it her blink 182 no booty
subtract him what do you subtract some
41 from blink 182 what do you get you
get blum 141 with you you get the
Backstreet goes yeah yeah get the
Backstreet Boys did you get 141 rum um
dude he looks like he's the biggest
Avril Lavigne fan of all time that's
what's going on he's just depressed
she's not making music anymore yeah
that's why he looks like Avril Lavigne's
senior this might be the mom or dad
I think our Levine's [ __ ] brother
that's what's going on I mean he looks
and this is rip mother if he's submitted
to be ripped is that correct yeah
absolutely submitted or does he think
we're gonna give him heroin what's going
on
let's just yeah this guy definitely
knows his way around a hit of smack you
feel me okay well this dudes a little
smack and act on there let's do this I
could do some smack for some you know
definitely man he has so much I mean
something's in his arm at all times
whether it's ink or hand you know and
but he seems like a guy who could
probably definitely
he seems like a guy that could hold down
a job for a couple of days as delivery
doing deliveries max yeah he seems like
he got in the middle of a night maybe in
Portland that will bring you bok choy or
something yeah I was gonna say he looks
like a Portland postmates that shows up
very late yeah probably not on time your
foods gonna be cold yeah but you want a
tip I'm just cuz you know he's
struggling yeah no matter what you order
you just get cigarettes from him just
always first order up but he's nice oh
he's so nice and his mom you know is
doing her best she's a little bit of a
hoarder and and the dad we don't know
what happened with the day and he's the
guy who goes I used to like that band
till they got [ __ ] - they blew up
yeah yeah we're cool man till you got
[ __ ] famous yeah acid bath was good
till they sold out you know did I run
one time I was on [ __ ] drugs and I
was at the time saver and time-saver
basically just a gas station you know
where they sell gas sell other stuff
inside which is our oddly the complete
opposite of gas food which is really a
rare mix to sell next to each other you
know very strange and uh and the lady I
went in there and I was so [ __ ] up
what were you high on bro
I don't remember just probably Christ
and some a couple of other uppers and
downers some Jamba Juice no no this is
before they had Jamba Juice yeah this me
just had to put all the fruit in your
mouth at once and do your own work
ain't no and uh we win in the let ego
which outweigh I've been an acid bath so
she said we didn't know that it was a
bad night because there's a band called
acid bath and bro were so [ __ ] up and
we couldn't tell what she was saying to
us because nor would ever think that
somebody would say where y'all been at
acid bath we've never heard of acid bath
uhm we were just on drugs yeah she's
like well then that acid bath final we
just want Mountain dude
yeah oh I just wanna just looking for
that cobrahead girl I just want him to
[ __ ] crawl into a bag of [ __ ]
Funyuns and just just go just look for
the Lord man I didn't know that drug
deal I know the clean feel yeah well
[ __ ] you
let's move on I'm joking man I'm happy
to see you today
sorry it's been a long weekend dude you
need some drugs now it's everyone's
favorite time it's a commercial from
King in the state hey do you know you
got a nice set of here on you but did
you know most guys I'm talking 66
percent of men lose their hair by 35 bro
35 and once you start losing it it's too
late dude you look in the merry go oh my
god too late yeah yeah you got you want
to be a real hair bear and have hair too
and I have some hair on my back even see
because you have so much here but if
you're not like feeling myself where I
got to worry about my hair running my
eyebrows go - for him ska my one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for the dudes well I'll say
this man I had hair taken out of the
back of my head and put into the front
of my head you know so I do think that
you know hair loss is like you know it's
something that a lot of men think about
trauma time because you like having hair
if you ever see all animal it has hair
and sometimes I get jealous yeah be an
animal hims connects you with real
doctors medical great solutions to treat
hair loss it's a well known generic
equivalents and name-brand prescriptions
to help you keep your hair
yeah the waiting rooms no awkward in
person doctor visits save hours by going
to for hems dot-com yep it's fo r hims
dot-com and you're also getting a lot of
those like the you know the vitamins and
the supplements that help you maintain
hair and keep healthy hair you want to
keep your hair healthy keep it healthy
and guess what King to Singh listeners
get a trial month of hymns for just $5
today right now while supplies last see
website for full details and safety info
this would cost hundreds if you went to
the doctor pharmacy yeah why spend
hundreds when you cannot spend hundreds
go to four hems dot-com / k 80s that's
fo r hims dot-com / k 80s for hems comm
slash cats going to paid abuse a deal
you ever had anyone go up T and go oh my
god you smell delicious
what are you wearing Theodore oh yeah
because one time I hit a couple of
Cinnabons under my shirt I know how that
goes man but you don't have to hide
Cinnabons anymore because they're set
bird
yeah Sen bird has found ways to have
great taste without breaking the bank
whether it's Versace Gucci Dolce Gabanna
cent bird comm keeps me smelling good
month after month
yeah and it's time to change up your
Cologne I mean a lot of us especially if
you're a human we just been wearing the
same thing that somebody bought us when
we're a junior in high school at
Christmas right right I'll be honest I
got you know I got the first two bottles
and any girl ever got me and she left me
and I'm still running around smelling
like I you know like me and her still
together
yeah I smell like Jersey Shore Sam bird
is a luxury fragrance script
subscription service mix up a cologne or
perfume routine B be on the cutting edge
of Cologne man smell nice you okay bro
nice I'll get max I don't smell nice
well it's time for you to smell nice
dude I've been sitting here by you and
smelling you and I'm not impressed man
okay well I gotta go SEM Bert well let
it fly straight it up up under your pits
scent Bert is more than 450 designer
brands for you to choose a cologne or
perfume from each month so you get that
monthly deal man that thing's coming
back and strike him back gucci tom ford
kenny cole Burberry prada oh and my dogs
are with that bird and with this
exclusive offer just for you guys you
get 50% off your first month today
that's seven dollars and fifty cents for
your first fragrance go to scent bird
comm /k ATS and use the code k ATS for
50% off your first month again that's
hit'em put that positive smelling scent
on the on the that positive smelling
gloss on that lot lizard of yours you
know what I'm saying go to scent bird
comm /k ATS and use our code K ATS for
50% off your first month
again that's SCE NT BIR d.com
/k ATS I'm spelling that for Brendan for
you to try your first cologne or perfume
for just seven dollars and fifty cents
sign on smell amazing
someone got spayed for Theo's haircut
what l see that next we got a little
debate club
we're still do even know how to do this
segment yet that's what I think I wanna
know how we ever figured out how to do
it
let's try good oh you're right first
Sammy Brown from Fresno California oh oh
dami im a me let's go to the brown
looking forward to seeing you in Brea
California in August cheez-its or
goldfish cheez-its for me all the time
that little blonde a Braveheart blonde a
cheese it's all [ __ ] day go
goldfish get on my goddamn face
Jesus they're delicious man really tell
me more you know what whatever she shot
I was gonna agree with oh really you're
that kind of guy yeah I was into it man
Oh yours a little bit you're just a
little snacks just a little long lover
yeah but your own side like though the
cheese at Tabasco you had those oh yeah
game change Tabasco out of Louisiana who
it's not yeah all right it's not I'm
just saying try and get the peppers
anywhere else dude wherever
yeah they grow on one island in
Louisiana Avery Island Tabasco though
Tabasco cheese it's for the win okay
Tabasco cheese's and then what are the
crackers you comparing these two cuz I
like more of a wheat then oh you like a
Triscuit no you want if you want to die
eat a Triscuit with no water
really oh dude good luck with that well
I feel so sad every time they're mailing
all those food to other countries and
stuff and they send a bunch of trick
it's trick it's to the Middle East
Tris kids yeah you got it yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] up centrist gifts to
Middle East or Africa it's crazy all you
bellies want Tris kids don't [ __ ] that's
suicide no dude my dad's 70 was growing
up to some of the people in his
neighborhood where you were eating dirt
and they were their bellies would get
all big from it from the dirt yeah for
meeting cuz they make little snacks out
of dirt and then eat him/her telling
they were real snacks yeah but these
people were breaking off slices to one
another oh you know a real slice of pie
yeah doing birthday Mother's hikes yeah
yeah
what is this well look first of all you
ever had a writ as we're haunted you
ever had rich dude I got some peanut
butter crackers in my bag I just
remembered I gotta get more yesterday
[ __ ] right you do man let's go to the
culture corner for some real snacks yeah
I'm sick of listening to your bitch-ass
you're aggressive today well I'm [ __ ]
angry dude I'm trying to quit smoking
cigarettes you idiot well why don't you
get a patch or something you don't think
I've tried it you don't think I'm
[ __ ] late in bed with six patches up
and down my [ __ ] legs boy yeah I
don't know dude let's go The Culture
Club
sorry I'm sorry bro Ritz cracker with
some Bologna and cheese on the sandwich
bro Jesus baloney on your hand
get off it's good we're talking solo bro
no peanut butter no you know Ritz you
can get the crackers with the peanut
butter he's saying no I respect what
he's saying he's saying Ritz with cheese
and Bologna man I'm talking straight-up
cracker for cracker pound-for-pound
crackers ain't talking about KKK ain't
talking about Newt Gingrich here telling
them neo nuts yeah do you think that
writs are the best best how they're good
hot they're not actually you know what
I'm going with those little Keebler farm
crackers those little hitters man white
devil oh those those rectangle Devils
god they're so good and they usually
give them at a salad bar yeah god
they're good what's with them to do I
could have 40 or 60 of them dude a pizza
at they used time at the salad bar we'd
go there my mom would get the salad and
I go get up there dude I get like 60
packs I'm gonna keep on under my pillow
at night I would take him home and in
the middle of night I would get up and
have a couple and go back to sleep I'm
still with homegirl though a little
Braveheart blondie with the cheese's
well I ain't sneaking a snack anywhere
around frickin Robin Hood over here okay
this girl will gun your ass down going
for a [ __ ] couple extra calories at
night I'd rather lay in bed and just
stay alive if I was staying at her house
but I think it's nice to see a woman do
archery you know she's the Katniss of
crackers and I'm down
this bad [ __ ] yeah I'm down with it too
Jesus
[Laughter]
you're you've really just lost it bro
you have dude you need a cigarette and
some dick what else we got 62% she's at
38% goldfish 60 was a cheese it yeah
I'll like them club crackers that's what
they're called yeah [ __ ] yeah those are
fancy though they're good this is a kid
a little bit pricey do you have them
Club crackers get it stealing from the
pizza boy but god damn then we're good
ocid okay at night have a couple Clayton
Schofield from Omaha place go let's go
but sorry gonna drive and drive no he's
an uber
[Music]
gang brah dude this man only could we
zoom in on him a little bit there at the
bottom is impossible just playing yet on
video right starvin yard market yeah
yard marker yard market that's good shut
out the yard market man shout-out to
your boy Clayton right there Scofield
okay can we hit that yeah just so we can
compare the two cuz that [ __ ] free
bird it makes me want to rob up hey oh
dude it makes me want to climb out of a
sinkhole and change the world
I just want to rob banks dude here's
stairway to heaven you kiddin rob a bank
giving those tight-ass pants okay it so
slow yes stairways at a Funeral
apparently oh it is cuz it's stairway to
have a stairway to a nap there's a place
in there huh God hit me with the [ __ ]
I just picture me as a drummer and you
sing in with that potato nose and I'm
gonna bat like this my shirt on just
shred it oh yeah in two weeks later
you're working at [ __ ] Trader Joe's
in the back you [ __ ] Muppet like yeah
whatever knows your potato rest of the
body you animal
okay and I also told people you text me
about possibly getting lip injections in
your top lip dude I don't need any
injections bro yeah things get any
bigger top lips a little slender buck oh
and you know you I don't need a top lip
[ __ ] I'm Lester hold on bro I'm Lester
Holt from Dateline oh dude we're Sammy
Sosa's lotion give some [ __ ] shrimp
so good cigarettes don't get a shrimp
get everyone here's shrimp I'm trying to
quit smoking cigarettes and you look
like bubble lump dude you look but you
look like someone broke into your body
and just sprayed a bunch of [ __ ]
drywall in here to eat you
like security a Cinnabon break you look
like your whole face is soundproof dude
you get ass bestest poisoning from your
own fat cells you dress like you only
fly in spirit well you have the most
frequent flyer miles on Spirit Airlines
dude spirits crazy one guy didn't have a
seat that is tied with a wall just hang
on like a bus and forget about drinks
but one lady pulled the thing and got
off or earlier her never up dad
I love spirit airline no you don't know
I don't I hate them
yeah man I don't fly them yeah what else
you got I don't mind
I like spirit if I want to turn up a
little bit if I want to cop a gram and
[ __ ] get get ratchet I'll get been in
the back son just I love like I like a
[Laughter]
Brokeback here man yeah - the parade's
are over who's not gay at 30,000 feet
stop smoking cigarettes just turn
camping yeah a lot of side effects read
the packaging bro yeah you right all
right what do you got the stairway to
heaven or free bird yes oh that's right
if I mean tomorrow
Freebird Freebird you were to run two
Raptors sorry you a hi boy
just letting you know that a world
champs are right now smoking cigarettes
Negatron Raptors fan yeah I'm you bro
wow I'm you today - hi boys I'm a
Toronto Raptors fan dude a mega team
makes me want to suck - I wanna fly
spirit I can't
oh I'm Brenda today lot lizards walk
lizards one Thea no I got this one lady
named
mrs. grant songs and she's little rocks
and we would all run and it was crazy
man she had a big head go gay gay gay
gay no told you bro but keep touching me
let's move this along bro for this
battleship sinks dude okay you guys are
going to hell man
not all of you but some of you are 56%
of people you went with stairway to
heaven
56 looking I know I just agree yeah blue
yeah no I think it's free bird huh yeah
free bird all day yeah you can't cuz
Freiburg gives you the option at the end
of hug or you know even make it free
bird makes me want to buy a Crimson Tide
shirt and yell out racial slurs really
reason I don't know why you could just
cheer for the team and not do that know
every third quarter they get race
reporter yes it's called racist third is
it really that yeah that's how they stay
undefeated well I've lost all my jobs
down ah what else do we got a Justin
Pratt
this is Justin Pratt oh you put the
church probably yo what up Brendan went
up field Justin coming to you at a South
Carolina just got a quick little late
night workout session in so forgive me
for being on the dark side of the video
but I got a quick little debate club
topic for you guys
would you rather [ __ ] your pants just a
little bit every single time someone
announces your name no or would you
rather get a full-blown boner in your
pants every single time you have a
conversation with the woman me
personally I can't really decide I think
both are equally as bad I mean I
probably go as [ __ ] in my pants
watch doesn't mean you could wear
diapers there's a couple of options but
you really can't hide a full-blown hog
in your pants and you're talking to a
lady I know you guys are entertainers
doing shows so every time somebody
announces your name brings up onstage
that ass is blasting think gang gang
buzz-buzz I love you guys and everything
you do always looking out for it keep on
keepin on boys love you man buzz-buzz
that ass is blasting bro that's
something something you would say first
of all yes I read your book simply a fan
well that's entitle my book this ass is
flat say not surprised stop smoking
cigarettes and wrote this book of my ass
blasting it's New York Times bestseller
yeah this one's pretty easy definitely
pop that [ __ ] bow
every time I talk to a girl I'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants return announces my name
yeah plus the bonus for the fun yeah how
are you gonna hide it you tuck it up
like a telescope you tuck it up tuck it
down like a know tuck it down like a
psychopath yeah it's tough tuck you down
like a pound sword like you talked you
down like a sword like it's [ __ ]
Braveheart or you tuck it down like it's
Gonzo's nose in a ski mask or you just
shark that [ __ ] and leave it up that's
what I do well do defend you measure
grow I'll [ __ ] roll right through the
wedding party about with that shotgun oh
you just leave it out I'll do the Loch
Ness monster how just peek out the top
my pan bring up a picture they just
found an alligator with a knife in its
head and everybody's looking for it
really yeah because I think alligators
are tired of people making money off
their meat so like I were just gonna cut
off ourselves and sell it ourselves
cut out the middleman there you go no
goddamn boots and I've had Gator right
there boy that case is on the search is
always probably dead what kind of [ __ ]
stabbed him in the face who stabbed an
alligator one of the most evil creatures
know that evil alligators doing
alligator [ __ ] man yeah like biting
people oh yeah if you're in the water
like a dumbass that's beautiful look at
that thing that's dopest many fishes
he's got now he's the only one rolling
around what a frickin knife dude he now
eat no but he might have a birthday cake
who stabbed him with the knife from out
backstage [ __ ] military knife that's
that [ __ ] flaming young spitter from
[ __ ] out back dude my Grammys this
feeling bro it's filet mignon not
flaming young okay we can play young too
you know that's that sirloin [ __ ]
knife from Outback you know that's
exactly what it is what else we got what
was the question what was the guy's [ __ ]
your pants let people say your name or
get a boner on Botox a lady both said
boner
yeah and that's an insane question
brother I think I mean did you think
about the question first and you seem
like a nice guy and I'm glad you're
getting Fitness in and everything but
you have to think about questions before
you just say them out loud you know you
have to maybe should ran that by
somebody maybe yeah and a boner man look
I'd be happy to get a boner you know I
haven't had a naturally induced boner
except out of sleeper on an airplane
that's when I get those bones yeah
you're praised for them yeah look some
good heat in your pants to keep you you
know it's our toes you want to get OHS
yeah we gonna bust nuts yeah so what
they need is coffee that makes you dick
hard
oh that's not a bad idea sure isn't a
little viagra in that car another idea
that I came up with and I'm still
waiting to market Olive kados crossbreed
the olive with the avocado and a nation
was born and don't deny you want to say
it's a good idea to look at them you can
see the good idea ideas I don't want the
olive avocado the olive kado it's called
say it say it so I don't want it you
ever had a grapple no grape in an apple
oh yeah actually great but an apple
sounds good do they make them no they
don't rattles no that growls they're
called grapples their giant apples well
I'll tell you this
I'd rather not get a grapple in my pants
like this guy wants to after he's
working out maybe lay off that custom
protein powder dude you know back off
the T cells or whatever you're buying on
the inner grapples back off that whey
protein yeah yeah I better grab all my
son loads but yeah shout out South
Carolina man thank you for the
contribution and think through your
questions next time though and also look
at that are you sure this isn't just a
an outtake from that movie Drive did you
see this guy's video yeah go get a grap
on think of a better question it was
better than the whole movie I felt like
what else you got d 93% of people went
with boners yeah [ __ ] they're bang well
7 out of 100 people do so that's let's
just Kelly something about the fanbase
yeah seven of them [ __ ] in the pants up
next is a little flop my hunt all right
we're gonna start with our Brooke
I can't tell just Brooke kept one black
guy look it's crossdresser Oh Brooke is
a man yes no no no no no Brooke and
let's take that part out actually can we
do that yeah I want to come for command
but also yes also decide first can we
look at Brooke again dude that Brooke is
a fine young aunt and it says she can
you look what can you look for another
second
I will say this I don't want to get
ahead but contest with her that's all I
say yeah I'll say this Brooke
it says flaunt my aunt yeah if I had
this aunt do it I would definitely let
her babysit me dude where's Pete my
uncle yeah say hey dudes get these aunts
all the goddamn time
so uncle every now and then we want no
we're looking at women you I know I'm
just saying Pete my uncle don't out
yourself do your friends and family is
supposed to do that dude you stopped
smoking cigarettes and your day now I
think we should celebrate it by peep and
uncles there's side effects on the
packaging you and I whatever will you
tell us some stuff about this beautiful
lady we didn't think about this she
works in a doll factory favorite food is
chocolate-covered bananas Jan wants them
to be the one to break Theo out of his
slump
oh he's in that she oh she wants me a
slump-buster what's her name uh Brooke
I'm gonna get a cam right here Brooke
you know I get to the cheese gotta go
through the B hey Brenda with the first
successful rhyme of 2019 Hey
unbelievable only took him six 17
episode although on Brooke my friends
gay now so we have to figure it out
yep I'm gay you'll know it all right you
idiot you better bring cigarettes girl
you better bring cigarettes touch me bro
don't touch me bro I'm shout out to aunt
Brooke I'm not mad her favorite food
chocolate bananas okay what do you think
of that D what are you trying to imply
there buddy I'm just saying I'd like it
well her opinion I don't like it it's
basically it's a banana in blackface and
I think that it's wrong
I don't you guys have ever seen it or
not I don't want to say it don't I don't
wanna see it I feel like the little
racist yeah now our dark chocolate
banana is really it's good that is
pretty good the melody thing Derek what
do you think about this dime right here
with that mascara on her eye she looks
like one of those girls from the point
of videos with the mascara run ya know
the [ __ ] girls yes is she holding a
cookie or is that slice of pizza
what's he'd say you know it is pizza is
that Pete's are we sure is this Dave
Portnoy in a freaking disguise ma'am oh
god man why does she uh why'd she have a
Barbie thing uh what's going on here
what what do you mean she works at a
doll factory oh she works at a doll
factory so maybe get a factory mm-hmm oh
they said a dog factor what is that
Pet Smart Oh like a puppy mill what
where do you live it in your head dog
factor again Oh Brooke if you want to
get to the honey you gotta go through B
you [ __ ] up your own life get up well
I'll talk about full like it on
cigarettes need cigarettes
look I say Brooke got them front cookies
man them hitters them tits and uh and if
this is a real aunt because there's a
lot of stuff going on here she's got
that mask area like your boy said Derek
zoom in on that I hold the [ __ ] dude
there's [ __ ] all over no one's noticed
this its semen in it [ __ ] semen roll
is she I think deal for this a man dude
that's not a band she's making a porno
and this is the end of it you know what
don't cut out the part I said in the
beginning cuz I was trying to go back to
this look at the whole thing on here the
blonde hair doesn't match the rest of
her hair this is a man's face and he got
busted on he must be off cigarettes Oh
God experience he's off cigarettes he
works at a doll factory this is a young
fella man this is a nice young man who
enjoys pizza and getting loads on his
face well who notice I'm a detective
I think 48 I Hey
case off you're a detective dude you're
the worst attack give you six minutes
praise in this young lass dude what are
you talking I stick I'm out taking her
out for a good time first thing I said
was that this young fella
zoom in running the cameras see the
[ __ ] semen on this dude but what does
this earn turned into man I don't wanna
be a part of anything like this man yeah
let's not well let's put this on this
town but I ain't doing this stuff when
I'm looking at semen on some fellow man
it might be sweat though any sweat
that's thick dick sweat out of
somebody's nuts it is dude I'm serious
man we can do it this time I'm not
looking at this kind of stuff I didn't
come here to look at this go to the next
one Darius your mother weren't you
looking at this [ __ ] no she would not
she wouldn't like it Jesus all right
dude
up next we got great uh or philia it's
brittle failure damn now here's a this
is a lady I could work with this one of
them Florida bad girls right there let
me see your zoom in on her she got that
frozen treat or she having a little sack
of Oh made him to go wieners what it was
called what's those can of wieners it
they have them little be honest I watch
a lot of first 48 you must watch first
2048 bro
it takes you the longest time ever to
solve a crime bro you're like
encyclopedia [ __ ] Brown that's your name
right
forever to solve man the first thing I
said was this looks like a man take that
out if you want to hurt their feelings
leave it in now if you're sending
whoever that is you're sending them in
here with semen on us you gotta tighten
up yeah your life together man uh no I
wouldn't seem it on your friend and
taking pictures of him you guys ready
you know we're gone I mean a goddamn
mind that's not what we're an effort to
look trapped or something that's
something written on their shirt I don't
even want to go back and look at that
yeah send it to encyclopedia big brown
over here he'll solve it before you're
probably about twenty thirty we'll see
this woman man
she looks nice it's got the croc song
with the socks yeah you got to be a
certain age wear Crocs with socks oh
she's a crocodile boy I like it
grandma crocodile he's got those floral
plant legs I like that the kind of pant
legs that you could blend in with a lot
of furniture too if you get that floral
print sure she could stand by a curtain
and you know she's half of her body's
playing hide-and-seek automatically got
a bad hat on what a sheet and there's
that a nice sort of power bar of some
well apparently she loves cookies and
snacks even though she's a diabetic oh
yank stir I love that don't let diabetes
hold you down keep you thinking well
she's gonna have sugar issues should be
in a wheelchair in no time but maybe or
it's all fake fake news you know I'm
saying keeping that sugar girl Esther
she looks healthy she looks fine legs
crossed
enjoying a cloudy day she might have
liya BTW she might just be lying as well
snacks
her favorite hobbies are cooking and
making up illnesses you see a churro all
the way from here my man yeah it is a
churro yeah oh it is a churro huh
pictures will vulgar now that's a
cherrylle I love she's taking it
straight to the dome to do yeah deep
throwing that churl Wow and look at that
soft palate she has you can see her
she's showing half of her palate mm-hmm
dude if she's yeah faking diabetes man
she just that's basically just become an
American tradition dude she's yeah
she'll be fine everyone has diabetes now
yeah yourself a shot every hour oh yeah
you see like a whole group of people at
the airport like it just the wheelchair
club like a group of dolphins just going
by you know just Disneyland it's a whole
[ __ ] trove oh oh really
whole trope oh yeah and they throw fish
up in the air fair forum mm-hm
but yeah she's in like a beautiful young
lady what's her name again great art or
philia or Celia to Ophelia yeah she was
in that but that Greek tragedy to I
think wasn't she
I think so I think I know what you're
talking about so she deserves a break if
she's been on them battleships and all
that I chose to though oh yeah beautiful
treats huh what else you got d last one
we got aunt Brenda aunt Brenda dead well
in part Brenda and aren't theo
oh we got two of other Turnus in there
girls oh damn I'm kind of behind boy
attack welcome to the bank is dime time
now look like of two nickels though I
look like [ __ ] as a girl you look like a
nickel and five pennies brother and you
over here in the dime were old off do
you pretty good there like a no idea
yeah penny for your thoughts
time for your time baby time time son
damn bro you look like somebody that's
gonna run for office at school dude in
college dude and I look like somebody
that's out there [ __ ] you look like
you're on CNN right [ __ ] about trunk
apparently they mix mine with a rat cuz
I just have a rats face and teeth now in
that picture it's not go it's just a
picture of you I don't know man
damn I wish you had a sister that looked
like that I do a sister looks just like
me actually really I put on sprayed
earring lines really yeah I can hear
what you said you put on Spirit Airlines
oh yeah I'm fire we're countdown oh
you're disgusting dude she's underage oh
dude no I'm saying if this was your
sister yeah what are you saying now
where are you what are we doing which is
GPS your life bro and [ __ ] odd take
the night wish you were a girl that
looked like that sick of this ugly
mother what else we got up next we got a
little relationship advice oh my
favorite part
VP COO sorry hi boy um I feel like we're
helping the nation out with this
relationship advice yeah somebody call
me other than said that they enjoyed it
our first one is from Angelo from San
Diego this is Angelo Angelo or Angela
Angelo with the show I don't know
anymore I don't know anymore
yeah what are we gonna get at your show
what's up Brad man what's up the whole
lot of gang [ __ ] buzz buzz gang bro I'm
coming to you guys for some dating
advice I'm 23 years old and
I consider myself to be you know in
decent shape I mean I work out five six
days a week
I trained that muy Thai that one
two-hitter
interactive got a job in school but I
just can't seem to find the one every
girl that's interested either has a
boyfriend
most the time or I don't know if they're
lying to me or what but yeah so do I
just start pulling up on girls in the
gym that are squatting and asking for a
spot or do I try to help her on that
deadlift form you know what I'm saying
like how do I go about this doing this
it's hard out here in the streets for
for a 23 year old and I don't think it
should be that hard I mean I see some
ugly dudes pull some timey die mm-hmm
yeah that's for sure [ __ ] I'm at
least a hard seven bro and I can't even
I can't even five buddy so okay I don't
know what to do hopefully you guys can
help me out there
whole lot of gang [ __ ] gang bro buzz
buzz good luck it you think I could be
on cocaine cuz the curtains are really
drawing close together and swords
hanging behind him on the wall as well
if you noticed that and that's enough
both of those are signs of cocaine he's
got a cat here cat what do you think's
going on with this young man I don't
know what's going on but absolutely do
not come to a girl while she's squatting
her deadlifting that's so annoying it's
a bad idea yeah because she means
business if she's squatting exactly I
say go up to her compliment her on like
how strong she is and then just walk
away damn girls that 315 pounds have a
good night yeah I'm more inclined to pay
attention to guys who give me a nice
compliment and just go about their day
then guys who try to linger I'm like oh
you don't linger and then they give you
advice and [ __ ] what if he asked her hey
you must split a protein smoothie after
this I don't know where your mouth has
been no wow he's not gonna baby bird it
to him he's not gonna he's gonna get
your own straw yeah one cup two straws
baby yeah I mean I think this guy
obviously you know could have been doing
some cocaine I think because they got
the curtains drawn the swords and look
I've been there brother you know I got
swords at home you know and I got thick
curtains brother so I've seen that
going on and uh and I think you you seem
like a god it's staying in shape you
could probably find a decent lady you're
only 23 man post some pics on this
screen with your shirt off at the beach
bro they're in come crawling to you what
if you're looking for a real wife I also
think you could consider an import he's
23 you don't need to order a Russian
bride you 23 just get on them them apps
the kids do diem some dicks he got this
bro I just don't think he's being active
enough spent too much gotta in time in
the gym and playing [ __ ] swords yeah
and look I like swords man I think it's
probably one of the best weapons you
could use if the Korean you know guns
went out of business or whatever what do
you think Dee what would you do with him
stop don't call yourself a seven you
know relax on yourself numbers he said a
hard seven well what do you give them
Cal what's a girl give up and then we'll
go around the guys his cats tight me she
wouldn't she likes Asians
I like nerdy guys he might be nerdy
xenon knives and yeah maybe I mean he
spends he might be spent too much time
in the gym
what do you give him cat one to ten for
my body diced he's Bob oh you know I'm
gonna give him a five oh he seems like a
very nice guy but for my type I like
nerdy guys yeah if I can't beat your ass
I probably am not attracted to you wow
you're like a praying mantis yeah where
they have sex with the male's and rip
their heads off yep what do you think
about that 505 I don't like the
personality it's already like bro you
think you're hot get out of here your
Gardens like I'm here
sevens like camp counselors like we're
get the gap cute hot you know I'm cool
with this happen and he's bodied up
seems like a nice feller fan of the show
I give him an a brother body a your Nate
dude go get a lifeguard job be a [ __ ]
lifeguard I'll be a blood donor if you
got a healthy blowing man you got to get
out there and give blood dude a lot of
these guys you know they got good blood
they're here [ __ ] around you know and
uh if you got nine or however many pints
you have in you 11 what is it 12 well
yeah I mean if you could give at least
one you can do one drop sign off
somewhere if you're healthy like that
you know I can't donate blood though you
know cuz i used steroids when i was
young and they say you can't go got
against you yeah you can't donate blood
so i'll still donate a little and
sometimes not tell them because i know
i'm good but but also someone might need
that testosterone in their body that's
what I'm saying break jack I never heard
anybody drop a [ __ ] half ounce
addition to some of these twinks brodo
give them a couple extra hours out there
on the catwalk that's all I'm trying to
say power bottoms but look man a hard
seven dude I think it's some honesty at
least the guys not giving himself at
eight or a nine but you got to get
outdoors man you got to take your sword
outdoors yeah okay doors so open the
Curtis yep it up live action role play
there you go
get that LARP boy get that LARP slam
them DMS good luck my man I'll give you
a hard sell LARP lizards bro
lot of LARP lizards dude you guys ready
for some King under sting I wanna help
negative Theo out over here dude I told
you I'm trying to good cigarettes
there's one man you should be happy yeah
first up is Phillip from Santa Rosa this
is Phillip oh damn Brandon Theodore for
you guys I think it was only for
psychopaths what do you think driving
shirtless can't get her sting it
gangbang buzz-buzz a little soft we saw
he's heavy in the gang was soft in the
buzz my kind of guy you know yeah you
got some pepperoni nipples as well
god it's tough the only time you can
really take your shirt off is if you're
in a topless [ __ ] Jeep Wrangler yeah
other than that you're a pair of season
maybe I don't know some sort of chrysler
sebring it's probably not too cool you
know I'm saying you can attract the
wrong dudes when you're doing that well
I tend to disagree with you Brendan
he's got those he he doesn't his nipples
are more like kind of like the ends of
those Vienna sausages bruh you know Sam
he's got this Vienna Bossa jizz if you
know what I'm talking about bro he's got
those hard hitters brother than [ __ ]
Channel pick up great here then man
tenez bro he's got those [ __ ] nips
sportin man yeah and I'll say this man
I'll tell you this I had a 1984 Jimmy
GMC Jimmy car and I took the doors off
that [ __ ] at a certain point I got
jealous as my friends had nice jeeps and
stuff you took the doors off so I just
took all the doors off yeah that's dope
and you'd do that if your car doesn't
have doors you can take your shirt off
yeah and so once you have the doors off
then it was like having a jeep man it
ran hot so I had to get out and put
water in it all the time but still once
you have the seat belt on your doors are
off I didn't give a [ __ ] if the thing
you know got water in it because it was
only worth about maybe $750 sure so
you're like Mad Max I bet yeah and it
felt just like Mad Max man and that's
the thing legally you can do that as
long as you're especially in Tucson
Arizona over there if Colvin Pantano so
if you have that doors off then you can
make anything a jeep but I say shirt off
doors off dick on let's go positive
attitude doors off shirts off yeah
that's what I say that's what I'm saying
dude and I'm talking also Poirier in the
second round you're mean we got David
Pryor from Australia okay then David
here from Western Sydney Australia yeah
most specifically black tan that's the
suburb actual place that we live he's
backed in lockdown don't I think you say
in the background we've got some
kangaroos having a Costco ball kiddies
happens to be in my place of employment
they pay me the good monies want to know
how you think about it they think about
them boat hitters and comment for you
guys to come wait for you to come back
to Australia Theo unfortunately I missed
it oh but we'll get you next time
Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz man shout
out to our Australia bro shot out to
Western Sydney shut out the Kangaroos
um then bolt gets on my nerves I don't
need 19 pounds of oatmeal you know I'm
saying I'm trying to get in and out it's
too much really you do much bro you look
like 19 pounds of oatmeal with the eyes
brother okay so you need to take a cart
down your own aisle it's just on my
thing it's too much man
I don't need [ __ ] 20 pounds of Costco
[ __ ] toothpaste just too much and
usually their samples are terrible like
do you do want to try the yogurt and I
don't want to try the [ __ ] yogurt
that's been out for hours but the
samples at Costco what do you think
about about this one Derick dude I go to
Costco for the samples dawg you'll need
a [ __ ] membership let him say what he
thinks Brendon he doesn't need help he's
an adult I like it cuz it's a warehouse
full of samples like a universal studio
ride a sample good you can really just
lay on the front of somebody's car plank
on a cart and with your mouth open a
shark can just cruise through that thing
I love that idea man I like it look I
like Costco because dude some of the
samples is too big I had a [ __ ] eight
core samples the other day you know I'm
saying I'm I'm knuckle deep in a little
[ __ ] prime rib over there dude you
can get a nice meal there too their hot
dogs churros pizza pretty cheap too long
a restaurant on the side we don't need
the stupid membership yeah hires there
yeah rugs TV theaters sick man oh yeah I
got a television uh fill with vanilla
pudding you can get anything you want at
Costco man you can get a tire fill with
[ __ ] all right frozen raspberries I
bought 75 blueberry muffins the other
day probably get through ten of them
yeah also that is Brennan's nickname on
grindr blueberry muffin t-55 and I know
that code language that's how you're
sending it out to these guys
he does it every episode he picks up a
baked good and then a number with it and
they know what's up but I'll say this
man I think you cruised through there
you know they got the guy with the
[ __ ] yogurt gun he'll shoot a half
quarter yogurt damn right
but now also it's dangerous in there you
get into some of the deep areas in there
in the middle east of Costco they got
people starving in there people in tents
people you know that can't find their
way out they had a man in there that
they found took seven days to find him
it's too big too much going on it's too
big man days but I'm a fan of Costco
overall you see people sprained their
back pushing on you know pushing forty
pound sacks of of frosted flakes to
their car oh how about the checkout line
no it takes forever forever the dude
bought a car in front of you 70 pounds
of [ __ ] peanut butter oh yeah they
got a scan that car dude's got a tires
he's in a Toyota Tercel with a trunk
full of crunchy and that dudes trying to
get out the main line yeah GTH boy go to
hell i King Costco overall though yeah
and thank you for the submission to see
the ones with kangaroos in the backyard
that's know shout out have fun in there
today man over there at the Costco dude
you know what you could do also you know
maybe sneak a couple of snack here's the
thing at Costco you can't even sneak
food into the back I used to work at a
grocery rights to do check out they do
on break I would walk down an aisle pick
up everything off the I'll go straight
to the snack room yeah I don't or
bathroom and eat it in there it's
exactly whippets come back to work do I
do I got fire cuz reading the magazines
eating all the food I got fired here's
nothing about Costco the [ __ ] beef
jerky it's insane oh yeah the briefcase
of me oh that's brief jerky or
wild boar jerky [ __ ] we look at Willy
Loman of teriyaki break at that brief
jerky what I'm saying this is this man
that's the problem at Costco you can't
even get a quick snack and sneak off
something and hide it no because
everything is too damn big you can't run
into the into the gas station and you
can't run into the bathroom with uh with
uh with uh with an 11 pound string
cheese this can't be doing a [ __ ] 70
pound sack of [ __ ] nuts into the
bathroom oh it's smallest thing they
have
yeah man so not a great place to snack
it seems like a fun place to work ma'am
Kenya can't our last one boys this is
from Cory and Mike from Scranton
Pennsylvania did we say King it or sting
it we said King it but did we mean it
[Applause]
that's hilarious
feels international sport baby oh man
look do this I think they should let the
guys pour gasoline out the window while
they're going around the track so
there's more fires after a couple rounds
yeah I like when they fight each other
yeah how do they fight you with helmets
on like bump each other dude well yeah
what the [ __ ] man they both got the
helmets on each other oh I remember Tony
Stewart killed that guy that post mates
driver who got lost on the track even
hit that fella it's a wild world out
there man I went to a race this year one
of my first races and I loved it man I
don't in person it's great it's done
some [ __ ] right yeah but I heard in
person it's awesome in person it's
relaxing acts I mean you sit there it's
really chill the problem is you can't
see the if the scoreboard I went out
there the Auto Zone Speedway out here in
Fontana and if you can't see the
scoreboard really well you don't know
who's winning or who's losing who cares
though you know yeah any cars and
there's a lot there's one section right
there on the turn where a lot of men are
basically trying to hope they want it
because there's tires will fly off right
there trying to lose a spouse you know
you see a lot of males living right in
there [ __ ] the old ball-and-chain if
you can't afford to take them on that
cruise ship down to the Dominican
Republic and kill them like that like
people are doing you big pop bag
yeah you sit him on that tire corner
yeah there's a lot in the face back
Goodyear $5 do and that thing comes in
hot Mitchell sizzling and you know your
husband ladies you have to look out if
your husband is dressed for a funeral
when you go to a NASCAR event you got to
know what's going on don't get all
liquored up right there in that tire
catch turn yeah if your husband has
sleeves on you know something's up at a
NASCAR if he's bringing a shield and he
just get you a Mike's Hard Lemonade
sleeves on some slacks and not his
typical attire you know some shits about
to go down oh you about to catch a
Fiorelli to the dog
I don't know what those tires are called
but that's it fellas oh yo the dark arts
are alive today bro you're team one
you're still dark
well Toronto Raptors man shout out to
Canada shout out the dark and in other
countries as well
mm-hmm we the north we the north
Derrick's back welcome back Derrick man
thanks for having me back for what I'll
be back glad you're back
oh I'm in there next week dogged by
improv brother Oh Wham's day Friday
Saturday Brett improv get you some dim
hitters and I'll be there in Brea and
August so come on out and bring that our
bow and arrow shoot me while I'm on
stage try and shoot me yeah try and
shoot me next week easy to shoot Brendan
actually Brennan looks like don't one of
that little baby that Valentines baby
that has the gun which is nowadays like
this stupid yeah uh I was sick you big
dummy about Cupid thought it was Steve
oh you never got any Valentine's cards
if I didn't know but my but my buddy was
like that of the handsome kid is cool so
they gave him to me to give to him the
middleman Oh kinda like I am for you
with girls I'm the middleman yeah
whatever dude I'm lonely AF bro you look
lonely yeah well sure do
handsome kid in school you mean you got
both eyes that's here we're out
[Music]
the king
[Music]